[Music]
what's up you guys time once again for
the matinee show we're doing some stuff
like on Netflix maybe some other [ __ ]
we've been talking about this first one
that we're gonna talk about which is a
series on Netflix we've been talking
about this a little bit on the side
track show as we've been like watching
it over successive nights and everything
like that there's a good one this is
yeah this is I I have to say that this
is one of the best series that I've seen
recently yeah and easily one of the best
zombie series yes is kingdom it's up
there with like the first few seasons of
The Walking Dead yeah it's a lot it's
like a Korean Walking Dead but it's
happening in like the 1500s in the
Korean Middle Ages yeah and it's not
from a modern perspective it's from you
know it's like The Walking Dead but it
culturally it is from the viewpoint of
the 1500 s it's bizarre man it's good
they did it it's a really good idea like
for a zombie show because like I said
you know yes there's been like a zillion
like zombie movies and zombie series and
stuff like that and you would think that
you know there's not a lot of new [ __ ]
to do with it there is yeah but the way
that this like incorporated zombies into
what is already a really compelling kind
of period piece about like palace
intrigue and betrayal and you know and
honor and [ __ ] like that
so the way that they just kind of woves
a'm be is into it
yeah I don't know if it's been done
before maybe it has I have seen other
zombie movies that were set like in
different time periods but I have never
seen anything really exactly like this
yeah and I think it's like a great idea
it was a great idea we see zombies of
course you know it's a 1960s an
invention The Walking Dead this game
night of Living Dead
so you can't have Korean characters from
the 1500s using the word zombies yeah or
using the words Walking Dead so they are
describing the zombie apocalypse from a
1500s
Riaan point of view they can't call them
zombies they called it a plague and they
call it the infected or monsters they
call the monsters yeah but they don't
ever call them zombies and they're
trying to come up with scientific
theories based on old-fashioned Korean
science of what the hell this is which
this it's a brilliant it's a brilliant
honestly the the explanation that they
give for how the zombies like how people
are coming back from the dead yeah
that's pretty good
pretty plausible I mean it's a lot more
plausible than space radiation radiation
or you know something or just cuz right
they they they they've found evidence to
explain it in a very unique way a more
naturalistic way it's not supernatural
it's not it is an infection but it's not
a virus not a virus yeah so it's pretty
cool it's pretty cool I'm not I don't
want to steal the series thunder there's
only two short seasons up on Netflix it
is a Netflix original yeah season
probably for Korea I guess but the
subtitles on it are [ __ ] great
production levels great that really
transmitted it really transfers real
well over into American culture the
Koreans have been knocking it out of the
park lately they know how they have all
of the stuff that I've seen recently
like over the past six months a year
actually probably even more than that
because I've seen like some great ones
that go in a couple years back to every
single thing I've seen that's come out
of there has been [ __ ] great yeah
they're not they're not [ __ ] around
it's just classic storytelling good
storytelling now the first couple
seasons of The Walking Dead were very
brutal a lot of the main characters were
getting killed rigged regularly this one
not so much
characters that you do love died but it
takes a couple seasons for it to kick in
now one thing you gotta you gotta
remember is that a Korean season doesn't
seem to be very long it seems only like
six to eight there's six episodes each
okay so it's two seasons it's only six
episodes per season and this is
happening at the very beginning of the
Kurian zombie apocalypse I mean it
hasn't really it shows how the outbreak
started how they mitigated it and I'm
and when the movie ends the outbreak is
still not totally under control so it's
just and it's weird when it ends with
when the second season ends they kind of
they're just introducing a new character
in a wild way it kind of reminded me in
some ways kind of like the Korean
Michonne character mysterious woman
mysterious woman appears and then that's
it the thing I like about this one like
I don't know if the 3rd season has been
green-lighted yet I mean I I imagine it
probably will because this is getting
like almost universal acclaim across the
board the acting the sets the story
everything I mean and the thing about it
is that this is actually based on a
webcomic
called the Kingdom of the gods and I
don't know how long that's been going on
so I don't know if there's like more
material but I imagine there probably is
if it's been running a long time but so
the first season came out in January of
2019 and I think even before they were
finished with it Netflix ordered a
second season because I think maybe they
knew like how big a deal it was gonna be
because I remember like hearing kind of
a lot of buzz about it when the first
season came out and watching some
reviews of and people like really diggin
it and stuff and then you know the this
so the second season you know just came
out like a couple weeks ago it's good
because it's all it's only six episodes
the episodes are about forty to fifty
eight minutes depending so it's a fairly
easy thing to binge like in one because
it's less than six hours per you know
per season but I would say and I've seen
some other reviewers comparing this like
favorably to like Game of Thrones and
stuff like that where the production
quality the cinematography is beautiful
like all the lighting all the sets you
know all the acting is fantastic it's
just this big epic like scope yeah and
it's really really well done
I mean having lived in Korea for a year
of it
[ __ ] camp grieves near the DMZ this
movie this series is very very Korean
and one of the things I liked about it
is that it highlights how beautiful but
then again how terrifying [ __ ] Korea
is alright it's either a mountain or a
rice paddy
there isn't much flat land and when in
Korea and when it is flat they're gonna
put a rice paddy on it or some kind of
farm
it's just mountains coniferous or cone
or coniferous forests cone forest right
yeah yeah and you know mist Misty
Mountains it looks like some [ __ ] out of
the Lord of the Rings that's that's what
Korea looks like it's a very hot a
summer very cold in the winter and
culturally the the tone of the movie
spot-on because Korea was always a small
Empire trapped between huge powerful
empires the Chinese Empire in the
Japanese Empire and it was constantly
being crushed by two enemies that were
trying to take over basically the Korean
Peninsula was always fighting for for
its independence and its survival
it was always run by North Korean style
dictatorships
even before it was unified you could say
today you could say that North Korea
today is more Korean than South Korea
and traditionally you know traditionally
North Korea was basically tyrants and
warlords all fighting against Japan and
China and they call it that they haven't
shown the Chinese yeah but they showed
the Japanese yeah because that was like
something that was going on like around
the periphery so this is a great setting
for a series like this a zombie
apocalypse
type setting because Korea was kind of
on the edge of an apocalypse always it
was like a post-apocalyptic Society son
in some ways you know I was always being
crushed and and it talked a lot about
starvation starvation is a big part of
this movie it shows how yeah they were
starving
you know Korea was always oppressed by
external forces and internal forces yeah
and it definitely that's another thing
that like it's yes it's like a zombie
show but it also has a lot of you know
kind of all the twists and turns of like
the political environment at the time
the royal family and you know the the
you know massive class divisions between
like all these peasants that are like
dying they're getting open brutality and
torture yeah [ __ ] you know I mean
Koreans were good people man but in and
there are strong people you know I
served alongside I'm in military in the
military North KATUSAs and real strong
ROK army units were on the right and to
the left of my unit ROK army airborne
troops and ROK army paratroopers Special
Forces units that were there upon the
DMZ brutal brutal discipline they're
nothing like the Chinese army nothing
like the Japanese defense force Korean
Koreans were always tough and that's why
they're there entertainment from what
I'm seeing this goes back to train to
Busan what was that other good Korean
one that we just saw oh gosh like I said
we sent some the one with the one with
the the the witch
the witch the genetically and she which
subversion it's a protein based
entertainment it's very soy free there
they're Koreans understand hardship and
it comes across in their story talent
just love it I love it well and the cool
thing about this too is that not only
does it have like really it has great
gore like great brutal kind of stuff but
you get you know drawn in by that as
like a horror fan but you also get drawn
in because of the interactions of the
characters and all this intrigue and
[ __ ] like that that's going on like
aside from the zombie stuff and you get
really invested in you know kind of the
main character he's the crown prince Lee
Chang and kind of him and his friends
are like all the people that are like
trying to you know get to the bottom of
this kind of palace intrigue and
betrayal and everything and also trying
to figure out you know how they're gonna
fight the infection or like figure out
how it started and what they're gonna do
and all this other kind of stuff but you
really get involved in like the human
story behind them too and that's kind of
one thing
like I said a lot of the recent stuff
that we've seen like coming out of South
Korea parasite I saw the devil stuff
like that they seem they're just very
good at getting you invested in people's
characters almost effortlessly it seems
like you know what I mean they don't
like seem to be making an effort to be
like hey like this character or be
interested in this character you just
are yeah they're kind of subtly do it
yeah yeah and they don't overplay that
they don't overplay the characters they
just kind of let it flow naturally it's
good storytelling yeah I can tell that
you know it wasn't always this way
you know when when I was younger and in
Korea you know I watched some Korean
movies of the day you know I mean from
the 80s and the 90s they they didn't
used to be this good they did start get
better in the 2000s like I love Musa the
warrior I don't know yet Korean version
of the title of that is it's kind of
like the Korean it's kind of like the
Korean medieval version of Saving
Private Ryan kind of that was a good one
too it's just their storytelling I think
has improved a lot I think I think it
kind of was based on some of the best
that Hollywood in other countries have
made you know what I mean
yeah the real old-school stuff that I
saw was Khanna
you know how Japanese anime doesn't make
much sense yeah that's the way your
average Korean movie used to be yeah
well maybe maybe they were more
influenced by Japanese man g7 and like
now they're kind of little more open to
like more influences yeah more of a kind
of a Shakespearean three stage you know
three part act type stories some things
like that things like character
development yeah which I guess I think a
lot of that had to do at the
walking-dead that was the first really
great series also you know remember how
good that Roman series was Spartacus
yeah first couple seasons the first
season of the first two the first two
season that was also fantastic I think
those two series really kind of changed
the game and you can see it in this you
can see it in this series here
yeah I mean one of the best things about
this like I said it gets you invested
like pretty much right away and all of
the character struggles and stuff and
then like the first season is epic but
it's a little more contained because
it's like a smaller type of thing where
they're just trying to figure out like
you know the infected and you know how
they work and where they're coming from
and then like the second season which
just dropped March 13th it just kind of
goes epic and scope where now you know
the the monsters the infected they're
kind of everywhere so they have to let
go from village to village and Palace to
Palace like trying to like stem the tide
of all this [ __ ] you know uh other than
all the other crap about like you know
the royal lineage and who's going to be
the king and all these other kind of
stuff all that stuff is happening too so
it's just kind of like it seems like one
where the the second season is really
like you know expanding out from the
first and like a really really
satisfying way and even though I mean
this is the kind of thing like I was
saying about the character development
and stuff like that I mean when
something bad happens to these
characters you're you're for real like
legitimately like oh man I love that guy
I mean it's like you know I mean we're a
lot of shows don't really you don't
really get that invest in the character
we you know where if something bad
happens to them you get like super
bummed out about it but this is one
that's like that yeah and you know this
is just one of the best series I've seen
on Netflix you can easily tell that each
episode costs almost two million dollars
right would you I don't think it was
supposed to cost that much but that's
just how much it costs yeah it's not
really sets these look like real
location they really do old Korean you
know forts and old old Korean buildings
you know it looks like stuff from the
fifteen hundreds costumes of [ __ ]
like hot seams are everything looks
really good and just the the characters
the way they act and the way they were
thinking you know they're trying to be
very 1500s so far you know I like it it
does kind of remind me a lot of the
Walking Dead I'm some ass in some ways
but in other ways they kind of improved
it because one of the weaknesses of The
Walking Dead was that there were too
many characters and
it was hard to keep track of so many
characters and it kind of muddled the
story at times which this one it really
mostly centers around four different
ones four or five different characters
so I like I think the story flowed a
little bit better yeah I mean it's a
pretty sprawling complicated story but
it doesn't ever feel like confusing or
muddled or anything like it's pretty
easy to keep track of all the tendrils
yeah and I really couldn't keep track of
all their names but you know you know
who they are by by their you know of
course the faces but you know the so be
is one of them right that's yeah okay
she was your doctor or nurse I couldn't
figure out if she was because sometimes
they called her a physician or a doctor
and then sometimes they called her a
nurse I think it's all the same thing
and maybe I don't know I mean she worked
her a doctor and stuff yeah she was like
her I she was probably my favorite
character I don't know it's like
everybody in this is like really good
like all like she's awesome like the you
know the crown prince is awesome like
all his like you know buddy's like his
his manservant or whatever that guy was
like his his personal guard or whatever
that guy was rad you know the guy that
seemed like a villain at the beginning
you know the one in the village yeah
made the soup or what oh yeah um who
actually like turned out to be kick-ass
it's just kind of like all of the
characters are good all of them are
compelling the story is compelling it
just and they kind of wrapped up a bunch
of story arcs at the end so so season
two does have a satisfying ending yeah
that way if it doesn't if it by there
it's kind of a status and it's okay but
they also did leave kind of a big big
teaser teaser like or cliffhanger you
know if they want to do the next season
they have somewhere to go with it they
included some damn mongolian death
coffins yeah stand him thanks google
what a mongolian death coffin is people
you see see what that is pretty
horrifying to me that would be like the
most horrible way to be imprisoned but
would suck a great deal yeah I have to
say so um but yeah I highly recommend it
yeah I mean per se if you're into zombie
stuff if you're into like historical
fiction especially like horror type
historical fiction yeah this is a really
it's a
in great series kana reminds if you like
Shintaro katsu like you know south to
ichi type samurai movies if you like
chinese medieval movies you know i mean
where they're you know the first emperor
type stuff it's Japanese samurai movies
if you like that and you like zombie
movies this is it yeah and like I said
it's it's got something for everybody
it's like there's drama there's intrigue
action there's gore it's just it's
really really good I mean just amazingly
good and yeah and they kind of kept it
kept it cultural too you know that they
were very concerned with bloodlines and
if you're you know if you ever lived in
Korea Korea is kind of like racially the
most homogeneous country in the world
they're obsessed with Korean bloodlines
you know their culture and they talk
about it in this yeah because this is
set like in the late 1500s yeah yeah so
always worried about family bloodlines
and Korean bloodlines now I kind of want
to go riebeck the webcomic
yeah it's pretty good I'm sure it is but
yeah definitely if you have to see the
chat did you happen he's in it more and
a Chinese member gets attend the
Japanese invaded we talked about it yeah
there to show some of that like yeah at
the end of like you know toward the or
actually that was the beginning of the
second season where they kind of talk
about the Japanese invading it yeah so
I'm imagining that they're I mean
there's a lot of directions they can you
can go with I didn't like end up you
know they showed a brief kind of
flashback where they were fighting the
Japanese and they said a badass samurai
cut and flip and a samurai was fighting
as obvious it was pretty cool
yeah whacking the heads up yeah
beheadings in this looked great yeah I
mean it did not I'm sure it was probably
CGI but it didn't look like it yeah it's
good movie the CGI looks better than
Walking Dead yeah and they find out all
kinds of weird ways to control these
zombies weird ways to term to save
people from becoming zombies a lot of
unique uniquely Korean ways of solving
the zombie problem I liked it yeah I
liked all this stuff that they kind of
added to zombie more yeah I mean that
was it there were still zombies
technically but really yeah but they had
some other like little kind of like a
rage zombie
yeah they were asked their brass but
there are different slightly different
rules yeah they can't be too rotten and
things like that
yeah it's like yeah they have like all
these different little changes in there
then just thinks about elements about
water and fire yeah they're trying to
figure out what temperature is a factor
and there's all kinds of stuff that
they're trying to figure out not there
there is still unanswered questions
though you know I guess they're they
just gotta learn it as they go yeah
because they definitely did leave a
couple of questions open like I said you
know the end of season two is still
satisfying in the sense that you get to
find out what happens all the characters
but they definitely left like a little
coda there right that opened up a bunch
of new questions like and I'm like I
said this has been getting such good
reviews in such good press I mean I
think it's got almost a hundred percent
on you know all the Rotten Tomatoes and
all of that so um you know it's way up
in the high 90s so I feel like this will
probably get a third season and I really
hope it does but not yeah they'd be dumb
not to because I mean this is like one
of the best series that have ever like
if you liked [ __ ] Walking Dead you'd
love this yeah
if you liked the game of Thrones you
probably like this yeah just you know
yeah it's definitely has that same big
like epic scope just like kind of in a
different when Lord of the Rings
yeah there's something the way it's shot
you know the way they shut is shoot the
the countryside of Korea was kind of
giving me flashbacks remember what it
was like what it looks like I could
almost smell what it smelled like
yeah yeah especially when they were
opening up all those canisters of kimchi
smelling that smell those farms and
stuff remember what it was like living
out there that happens every time I
watch a movie that said in Wales you
remember what it smelled like yeah yeah
yeah sheep all right yeah but yeah so
definitely check this one out this is I
recommend this to anybody just without
reservation cuz it's just awesome all
around
you
all right second thing we saw this week
also on Netflix and this was actually
recommended to me by several people and
I've been seeing it come up like in the
new releases and stuff like that and it
did look intriguing so we went ahead and
watched it last night this is the
platform not a bad movie this is
actually a pretty damn good movie this
is a Spanish film the Spanish title is
actually El Hoyo or the whole um this is
kind of like one of those like
allegorical horror films kind of like it
was like cube a lot of people have
compared it to cube or circle I don't
remember if we've reviewed that one or
not that might be on shutter or Netflix
or anything the one about like all the
people and they just wake up and they're
like in this room and like they get
zapped and they've to vote on who gets a
please I think it was supposed to be an
allegory about I guess Marxist ideology
maybe I didn't really have an ism well I
didn't really read it that way it here's
the thing it has like a lot of this is
one of those movies that the meaning of
it is gonna be like yeah I already seen
yeah well there's a couple of different
interpretations I don't really want to
get too much into it cuz I don't want to
spoil the movie yeah but basically what
the setup is is that there is this
essentially like a tower block or like a
prison or something although the
administration of it calls it a vertical
self-management center yeah and what it
is basically it's just like all these
levels and each level has to you know
prisoners on it and then there's like a
hole in the middle that goes all the way
down now once a day
this platform comes down from the top
which is level zero and it has all of
this like really like lavish like
banquet on it food on it but each level
it only stops for two minutes and like
as it goes farther and farther down
obviously because you know you know when
it stops at a level like everybody eats
as much as they can eat for two minutes
and then it goes down so by the time it
gets like down at the bottom there's
like nothing left even though
theoretically there's enough food to
feed everybody theoretically but see
there's no way though you could fit that
much food on a dent
well I think that's one of the that's
one of the things that they were kind of
pointing out like in the movie because
the thing about the movie is that okay
so the main guy who's in this you know
his name is goring which actually means
I was looking it up on Wikipedia like
all the names of the people cuz
everybody in this like I said this is an
allegorical horror film so every
character that's in it like their name
means something most of their names are
like food-related like this guy's name
means I think it means fried or
something like that so he is he has
voluntarily chosen to come into this
place because he will get a degree at
the end of it so he's supposed to be
there for what six months or a year or
something like that you know six months
yeah oh another thing too is that
Everett once a month everybody in the
tower block is like gassed and
unconscious and then they move everybody
around to different levels like
seemingly arbitrarily because the higher
up on a level you are the more food
you're gonna get yeah as this thing goes
down and you know they're not sure how
deep it goes yeah no one seems to know
no one really seems to know and then
when it's done I guess after everybody's
support has everybody has had a visit by
the table it goes back up yeah so
they're just trying to survive this [ __ ]
I mean to me that's a [ __ ] like
that'd be like the one of the worst
prisons you could possibly imagine yeah
and some guys have willingly gone into
it everything I think it's actually an
allegory for maybe purgatory or hell or
I think it might be I'm not gonna like I
said I don't wanna I'm trying not to
spoil anything because I I thought maybe
it was some kind of an analogy for
Marxist theory but if it was Pro Marxist
it failed what no I don't think that
what I think that's what it was yeah
there's there's a lot of like
implications like I said this is one of
the movies one of those movies were to
be read like a lot of different ways
it's very like you know in the sense
it's like Animal Farm or something like
that it's kind of like that where it's
just like a setup but it's still like a
really good like compelling movie like
the characters that's actual characters
escape they try in its ways it was
actually I think the original scripts
for this was supposed to be like a stage
play so and you can tell that but it's
um but it is very like cinematic in its
scope and [ __ ] like that so yeah so the
guy goring who comes in there
voluntarily oh and you can everybody can
bring one item with them like when they
come into this place and he has brought
and this is very significant he has
brought a copy of don quixote now one
interpretation of this movie is that he
is don quixote he is like like i mean he
was he's so he's on this ideological
quest which ends up failing because he
doesn't understand how the real world
we're sure he lost it lost in his own
delusions you know what I mean so some
people have like interpreted it that way
like you said some people have
interpreted like it in kind of a
biblical sense because when they find
out how many levels there are and how
many people there are and [ __ ] like that
that you doesn't really makes that
numerical thing has the significance
also but it's kind of like showing like
I said it's hard for me to talk about it
without giving too much away it's a
nightmarish idea when it is it starts to
unfold I'm like man I've had nightmares
that were kind of like this it is very
nice yeah where you're trapped in a
place and it gets more and more absurd
as it goes and then you get disturbed
then you eventually wake up like
shopping malls that never end and
escalators that go down but you go down
the escalator B he's still up at the top
somehow yeah I've had weird [ __ ] like
that that's kind of yeah this movie kind
of reminds it kind of comes across those
kind of dreams it's not it's something
that I recommend it you should watch it
try to figure it out it's very Franz cop
I'd have to see the thing I think I'd
have to see the thing a couple more
times - ah yeah this is in Spanish and
it's subtitled yeah the acting is very
good if you speak Portuguese you don't
really need the subtitles but it's good
this is one that definitely needs like
repeat viewings because there's a lot of
symbolism in there there's a lot of like
especially like with the whole panna
cotta thing like with the little girl
who may or may not be real
we're not really sure like I said
there's a whole Don Quixote type of
thing going on like the significance of
him bringing that book the significance
of the old character that Goering is
first paired with trim Agassi which
actually I think in Thai means thank you
um and kind of what what he brings to it
like why he has that knife and happened
why he ended up in this prison and
there's so there's kind of a whole thing
about and I like that they left like who
built this prison why are some people in
there for crimes like trim Agassi is why
did some people apply to go in there
voluntarily like Goering did and like
one of his other cellmates does later on
who actually used to work for the
administration that's all they call it
and then she went in there herself
voluntarily because she wanted to see
what was going on in there so it was it
seems like it was built as an experiment
I mean that's what I took from it maybe
not but because there does seem to be an
outside world in the sense that Goering
there's some there's some scenes of him
where he is applying or like
interviewing to go into this yeah I
don't think it's real though management
yeah I don't think I'm just saying that
it that it's implied that it was
designed as an experiment to see what
would happen you know if you had like
these descending levels yeah you know of
food yes and they're like I said they're
positing that there is enough food on
this thing that if everybody just ate
their share then everybody would get
enough but I but yeah I think as the
movie goes on they find out that that is
not the government grim hope yeah that
was just what they were telling them
yeah I don't think this prison I don't
think it's happening in the world worl
world
no it's allegory it's happening either
in and another dimension like in a
heaven or a hell where it's happening in
somebody's imagination or something like
that it's not it shows certain things
happening that couldn't happen and so I
think some of it might be in gorings
mind yeah I think some of it might be
well just the damn table going down
through
holes going down through the sails it's
not attached it's not attached so it's
antigravity this is something somebody's
dreaming up or it's something some it's
just a lesson they're trying to teach
the audience in a form of a movie it's
something like that it's weird this it
is it is entertaining though I liked it
very much
I mean now if you're squeamish it's
pretty gory there's like you know
there's cannibalism there's all kind of
like horrible [ __ ] yeah um also I
wouldn't recommend eating while you're
watching it just because even the food
that's coming out it's like so gross
because it's like as it goes down each
level and again it's over yeah people's
like you know people get [ __ ] on and
peed on and also so you know what I mean
so if you're squeamish you might like
want to avoid it but it's just like if
you like like allegorical do you know
what I'm gonna call this this is like
cube meets snowpiercer yes you know what
I mean this is very much like that like
I said there was a little bit of circle
it's a bit like I said it's kind of
Kafka esque you know what I mean in the
sense that it's just kind of this
allegorical thing with this big faceless
you know away the thing ended though it
didn't really end with in a satisfying
way to where it made me understand it I
got I was confused by the ending
I'd have to price see it again or
somehow reanalyze it whatever it is the
movie the movie isn't what it appears to
be you know I mean yeah it's it's it's
an allegory I think and it's it's weird
it might take me a couple times to watch
it or I might be reading into it it may
not be anything maybe I think I think
after I thought about the ending I think
I know what where they were going with
it like I think I know what they were
trying to say with it but like I said
there are other interpretations of it
too I've you know I've seen other people
like I cuz I was thinking about it and I
was like well I wonder like what's this
and that and I went and checked some
other people's and there's like at least
two or three other interpretations that
sound just as I was like okay yeah I can
see that you don't really have to
interpret any of this you can just watch
it you could just and it still
entertained yeah I mean it's still an
entertaining movie it doesn't have to be
things are as nightmarish prison yeah
like I don't want to imply that it's
like oh it's this big like arty-farty
like that you're not gonna be
enjoy it as a movie but yeah it's
definitely it's it's a grim movie but if
you like allegorical or if you like this
kind of just nightmarish I think he kind
of setups I think you'd be into it I
think it might be a nightmare yeah I
think it might well that yeah there
there is some evidence to say cuz some
of the stuff I'm not sure if it really
happened or not if then maybe the whole
thing didn't happen it feels like it's a
nightmare I've had nightmares kind of
like that yeah where you go down in an
elevator in the elevator just keeps
going them down and down and down and
down you're like where the fire but yeah
and the setup of it too reminds me a
little bit of like I said circle that
one where they were all just in that
room and I think I don't even remember
him yeah I thought we watched it but it
was a while back where where everybody
was like in these concentric circles and
then they had to vote on who got
electrocuted
you don't mean like every time the the
buzzer went off they had to like vote on
who got electrocute it was like a weird
like social commentary type of think
there's like all different kind of
people and they were trying to determine
like who was the shittiest person like
who deserved to get fried and [ __ ] like
that well the whole level thing is I
thought it had to do is kind of like a
class system yeah it is first but not
really because it changed every month
well they were kind of they were they
were kind of trying to I think they were
trying to illustrate that because that
it's human nature to like when the
people were like farther down like the
guy goring who's the main character he
starts out at level 48 right and the old
guy um you know trim Agassi who says to
him is like oh this one's not too bad
like it has been in lower ones in a
shitty area but um you know what I mean
so you would think that if you'd been
like in a low level and knew how much it
sucked that you would have more sympathy
for people that were underneath you when
you were higher up but they were showing
in this movie that that was not the case
that what people were doing was that you
know if you woke up and you were on
level six or whatever like like Goering
does at one point like you'll still like
[ __ ] on the people below you just
because they're below you even though
you've been in their position well all
these people are bad people they're
criminals no they weren't like a lot of
them were but were volunteered that
doesn't mean
criminal and that land that girl and
that little girl and that little girl if
she was really in there or not she
didn't have any choice about whether she
I think the meaning of it was is that no
matter what your if it has what it means
is what what it meant to me is that
everyone was equally pretty bad that's I
I didn't get that uh yeah didn't matter
what level they were on there was
[ __ ] on everybody below him and he
could show yeah that's what they were he
could change him all around it didn't
matter that's what they were saying they
were like even if you had been lower
down in numerous you were still like
it's she's still human nature to [ __ ] on
that's exactly what I just said that ya
know but that's what I so they're all
well I'm just saying that yeah they're
all bad that that's what I mean when I
was saying that it seemed like that that
this bill if if this like tower-like
existed in reality that it was built as
an experiment and they were all then
they had these high-and-mighty ideas
like if well if we all just ration the
food everyone will have something to eat
and it'll all just go and we'll all live
in harmony turned out no nothing true
well yeah because there was to me damn
levels well yeah because they know how
many levels that were I think it had
more to do with like a dispassionate
[ __ ] uncaring universe or that nature
doesn't give a [ __ ] about you and other
people don't give a [ __ ] about you
that's whatever think what it meant yeah
well that's yeah they're all in there on
their own yeah that's kind of what they
were like trying to like I said that was
kind of like what it was there was some
about some kind of kind of gift and a
message to God analogy I don't think
that's what it was I thought the people
at the top that were making the damn
food we're supposed to be the gods I
guess you could read it like that but I
thought giving an offering to the gods
yeah you could read it like that um but
it but that would have been that didn't
work though but I don't see I don't
think that's what it was
I think that they were well I see I
don't want to like spoil the end but I
think the people at the top the people
that were making the food like on level
zero
I don't think they knew what was going
on really because look because the one
character who had worked for the
administration but that came in later
she didn't know a lot about it either
that plays in right into what I told you
though because you see with the whole
concept of the day
the urge it's God as the devil or an
unknowing uncaring gods on Mount Olympus
that type of analogy yet out of an
things God's coming from the plural and
they don't know about you that's that's
all goes right and even though those
people at the top like that was looking
the food they might have thought that
that doing a good they were doing a good
thing in right now is gone but they
didn't realize that goes back to light
to unknowing gods from the plural so um
you could have so you could have
religious interpretations but not
Christian interpretations this is like
almost let's say what was that
pre-christian philosophy that was Roman
did I talk to them
but say what Mithra ISM no no I've
mentioned it many times before it's on
tip of my tongue Gnostic it's very
gnostic concept here you know
Gnosticism that's what it sounds like
god's coming from the plur alma
demiurges which are devil like gods or
God as the devil or God as the devil or
just ignorant gods that are unknowing
and uncaring or gods that have no
concept of the of the material world and
humans so when when they die there's no
reaction yeah so I think it might be
that - there might be a gnostic
interpretation to it well yeah I mean
but that's just my interpretation it
could be due to wrote this just came up
with some [ __ ] weird ideas some what
is this is definitely but it's
definitely allegorical and it was meant
to be allegorical but there are several
different interpretations of it and I
think all of them are probably equally
valid because I've seen like a couple of
different ones that I'm like yeah I
could say I could say were the gnostic
interpretation what it was is that
humans are individuals there isn't any
kind of collective people are kind of
like animalistic and don't give a [ __ ]
nature and itself is suffering there
isn't enough to go around for everyone
and people are supposed to die it's an
uncaring an accrual universe made by
ignorant gods that's would be an
announcer concertation yeah alright
and it you trying to make sense out of
it and make right or wrong out of it
it's all for nothing because the gods
that made it don't even know this is
chaos well that's like I said that might
be the interpretation of why that why
the main character like why he brought
Don Quixote yeah in with him because
that was kind of like the story of Don
Quixote where he was like this
delusional like he thought he was doing
good but I'm doing good he was trying to
do good but that's all the delusion
there wasn't enough food to go around
you might as well just you know eat as
much as you could which everyone was do
yeah and you might as well just [ __ ]
over the people because they they're
gonna [ __ ] you over there
there were yeah when they switch any I
like yes so so yeah this is a very even
Gnostic and it's a very grim movie but I
said but it's still and I still enjoyed
it because it still had like some kind
of black comedy um you know it had like
a cool I really liked the look of it
it's like very very sparse but you know
it was kind of had like this red kind of
thing and you know it's all kind of [ __ ]
but yeah this um it seems to be getting
a lot of buzz like I think it premiered
at the Toronto Film Festival like late
2019 or early 2019 and got like all kind
of prizes there like it got there like
the audience award so it was like the
audience's favorite out of all the
movies that they saw but yeah so it's on
Netflix and definitely check it out and
once you've seen it like let me know
like what your interpretation is I'm
trying you know we're trying not to
spoil too much of it but I might have it
right though more to think about it but
less I think it might be not a gnostic a
gnostic story yeah it yeah it could be
like I said that sounds totally legit
yeah but yeah definitely check it out
it's a really really worth watching like
one of the best movies I've seen on
there lately
you
okay third movie we saw this week on the
matinee was one that we rented on the
Xbox and it was one that we talked about
for the last couple weeks and we only
just now got around to seeing it because
we liked the look of the trailer
this is guns akimbo yeah had some
feedback some in the comment section was
like oh man it sucked I thought was
gonna be good got ten minutes into it I
couldn't take it and turn it off you
[ __ ] trip and dude is awesome I like
the movie I did well I thought it was a
lot of fun I mean it's not a serious
action movie in terms of you know what I
mean grim and realistic it's playful and
funny and lots of action
I mean it's constant action lots of gore
in it it's kind of funny gore though
totally it kind of reminded me of birds
the cross between birds of prey in John
wick 3 yeah it gave me like a little bit
of a Scott Pilgrim yeah I'm as well like
audio game type of yeah video game type
stuff and emoticons popping up talking
to each other kind of had a contemporary
vibe kind of like Ralph breaks the
internet kind of that was called Ralph
Gracie yeah a little bit you know like
that but I had a good time watching it
visually I thought I thought the movie
was awesome
yeah the lighting and it was like really
really cool because it's like a because
everything is like super exaggerated so
like I said this is definitely a video
game movie I can okay I can see why
somebody might not like it because it is
very like frenetic it is very like coked
out yeah if it sounds to be yeah but
that's kind of the style and I can I can
understand if like you think that's like
too much and it's like too spazzy and
you can't like deal with it but I
actually ended up really really liking
this a lot I thought it was a [ __ ]
blast the premise is basically the
running man yeah but it's being watched
by drones and it's illegal yeah one by a
kind of a kind of an underground crime
syndicate yeah and a bunch of money off
of pitting people to duels to the death
in public and little flying drones or
you know chasing them and follow
and everybody's logged in watching it
making comments you see the comments pop
up as the as [ __ ] happens the villain in
it or the super villain the guys in
charge of what was the name of that it's
called schism schism is the day of the
as II like it's an app that you buy see
you can watch this deathmatch and the
guy who's running it is the same dude
who was the the Jesus Freak cult leaders
the right hand man down a mother swon
brothers Juan and Mandy that Dan hey
that guy's Dennehy yeah this guy's in my
mind a rising star after Mandy
everything this dude and this one
everything this dude does is gonna be
cute I almost didn't recognize him
because he looked a lot different in
this one like he's like he looks like
our friend will he did actually like
yeah you know tattoo wills wills face
he's like that and we know soul
punk-rock guy looks just like that he's
[ __ ] crazy and I mean we'll [ __ ]
with each other [ __ ] with each other
for years anyway if I had the club he
reminds me a lot of will ya in the face
he looks a lot and uh it's imagine
running man had a baby with John wig I
know what the movies like with it but it
has comedy comedy well I said with a
Scott Pilgrim I'm laying back a watch
running man and there's a lot of comedy
and running I had forgotten how yeah how
much that was supposed to with Arnold
and everything yeah there's a lot of
comedy in it that kind of goes over your
head when you're a teenager or you know
watching the movie because you all
manage it's badass
actually so bad yeah actually if they
were to film running man today it would
be like this this is how they do they
need to because even though I love the
running man the classic original richard
dawson and everything yeah when you
actually get to the fight scenes not
much happens
yeah it's heavily edited so they had all
these cool characters like sub-zero and
you know who is the other guy electro
but they don't actually show them fight
yeah it's not real bloody this one's
pretty bloody people get that beggars
shot off headshots
dudes a total loser he writes code he's
been watching schism this is how it
starts his he tries to get back to this
girlfriend he's a dork he talks about
how you know he always wanted to be an
alpha male type [ __ ] warrior but he
was just a code monkey and it's not
really in him and somehow or another he
Gossett gets into a fight with somebody
online and when he wakes up the next
morning he's got guns [ __ ] screwed to
his hands they go right through the
flesh and there's no way he can take his
hands off the trigger he's got two gun
to Nakata it's kind of myth it's kind of
[ __ ] but I liked it anyway it was
two 1911's even though it said each one
of them had think had 40 rounds each
which in 1911 one carries seven I
thought it was six maybe fifty rounds
each or something I can't remember how
many rounds but it's kind of in a knob
so it's kind of like in a slightly
alternate future I guess when you see it
this is not I mean because it's set in a
mythical place called shrapnel City yeah
even though they actually shot it in
Auckland New Zealand and some of it was
shot in Munich in Germany as well yeah
you know because the the director Jason
Lee Houghton is a is from New Zealand so
yeah so they shot it there and like yeah
so the nebbishy character cuz normally
this schism like show you know this web
serie or web show or whatever is its
criminals essentially and they pick two
criminals of badasses against each other
right each other and people like you
know watch it like to see which one gets
killed and the how Daniel Radcliffe's
character gets involved in it his name
is Miles is because he was like talking
[ __ ] to like other people that were
commenting on it like saying it's like
you know you know criticizing them for
like watching this is entertainment of
blah blah blah so you know he was being
a keyboard warrior so uh you know the
the main guy that runs schism whose name
is Richter and the facial tattoo guy I
love like all their [ __ ] names like
what like the guy with the Mohawk I
think his name was [ __ ] yeah like
him first
at first I thought he was just calling
in magazines mad I'm like oh that's his
name yeah famous [ __ ] but yeah so um
so
they decide that they're gonna get this
they've never had this happen before
because all the people that are you know
fighting are usually like Psychopaths or
criminals or whatever so they decide to
get this kind of nebbishy character in
on it just so he can put his money where
his mouth is because he's been sitting
on his couch and talking [ __ ] talking
[ __ ] and everything like that so yeah
they they break in his house I'm like
both the guns to his hands and so
there's this whole thing where he has to
fight the character he was like the main
badass and she is like killed like a
whole bunch of people like in the less
she's like the reigning champion yeah
and her name is NYX and she is played by
Samara weaving who I mean she's [ __ ]
great she's Australian actually but she
started out like I think she started all
like soap operas and [ __ ]
but she was um she was great in [ __ ]
ready or not which should be reviewed
when we said when it came out in the
theaters a while back but she is like
[ __ ] fantastic in this yeah in this
movie the character Nick's reminds me so
much of my cousin Catherine crazy-ass
[ __ ] Cajun girl she loved it she
wente of course she wasn't as crazy as
this girl yeah cuz this are all super
great but yeah her mannerisms and [ __ ]
so it was her [ __ ] she said reminded me
a lot of my cousin but yeah
it is you can't take the movie seriously
it's pure entertainment I mean she the
girl weighs 90 pounds and in one scene
she wields a [ __ ] minigun we're like
straight out of the Terminator but it
worked
yeah it worked okay because it's not
supposed to be realistic yeah she weighs
90 pounds that weapons system fully live
ammo pack about 150 she shoots off
probably about 2000 $3000 7-6 - you know
cuz it the ammo goes fast out of a
minigun she's stand up on top of our do
it it kills it's a cartoon kind of movie
yeah super over-the-top so it makes me
real skeptical skeptical because why
wasn't this [ __ ] in an AMC theater it
would I think it got a limited
theatrical release I did well okay so
what ended up happening one it's not an
American movie it's an Uzi it's was made
in New Zealand yeah it didn't actually
premiere until September 9th
that was at the Toronto Film Festival
and then while it was at that and then I
think it played it Fantastic Fest and
then while it was at one of the
festivals like Sabin or whatever that
and that distribution company is they
picked it up and I think they gave it a
limited theatrical release this was like
a small company and then it went to VOD
like in but I think from what I could
determine I think in New Zealand it got
a theatrical release it just came out
like March 13th or something like that
I'm called I'm calling shenanigans call
shenanigans on this ship because this
movie I think the reason why they kept
this thing out of the damn theaters
because it would have competed very well
with a bunch of high budget [ __ ] - Holly
was coming out this book this is very
similar to birds appeal tonally it's
very similar but it's better than birds
of prey and I think that's why it didn't
show here it dizzy I mean I liked birds
of prey but like this this was that her
fun I think this one was a little bit
more fun than birds of prey yeah well I
don't I think this one was better
because it didn't have the baggage of
being a sequel and being a a comic book
movie yeah this I think it was already
original it was it really just a
completely original story it's it's own
thing so and I liked it better I thought
the action scenes were better yeah not
the way it was shot was a little bit
better it looked more like John wick 3
yeah like with all those really bright
like statuary colors like it's dark and
then there's like a riot right colors
and I just think artistically and
tonally I think it knocked it out of the
park it was a soundtrack - very good
soundtrack all covers from 80s and 90s
classics you know it's a frickin even
got Rick James super freak in it it's
got bowling blitz ballroom blitz of
those songs except for the Cypress Hill
one I think yeah it's like a Cypress oh
yeah I had some Cypress Hill in there
but that was that was an original just
like in good movie I have to say that
like some of my favorite scenes some of
the funniest scenes are like happened
early on with Daniel Radcliffe I have to
say like he's British everybody knows
that he was [ __ ] Harry Potter but um
you know what I mean so his
American accent I always played an
American in other movies as well like he
was in horns and [ __ ] like that but his
accent was like flawless you would not
know that that dude was not an American
yeah which is kind of crazy but him like
at the beginning you know he yeah he's
kind of a dork and everything but he's
still like kind of a lovable dork
so just him kind of like trying to get
up to speed with you know the situation
that he has been thrust into and like
all of this [ __ ] like you have guns
bolted to your hands like you can't put
on pants you can't take a crack I can't
pee like you can't can't do anything
with your phone he's like doing of his
nose and [ __ ] like because you can't get
the guns off and it's like there's just
a couple of great scenes with him like
talking to a homeless guy yeah like this
this guy from New Zealand I don't know
who that is but those but that [ __ ] was
[ __ ] funny
yeah but the scenes between the two of
them are really the humor spot-on the
violence is spot-on it it does a lot of
callbacks to other 80s action movies in
terms of the guns if you pay attention
to guns and you know gods you'll know
the exact jokes you know and I mean like
she shows up with the minigun from
Terminator certain guys have [ __ ]
desert eagles which was [ __ ] in the
80s that gun was just a damn stereotype
you know so and then you know [ __ ]
large-bore 500 Magnum revolvers or
whatever you know if I could [ __ ] I
don't know what cat maybe 454 I don't
know but there's just cool gods in it
and tropes and then the trope might you
think a trope is gonna happen and it
doesn't yeah oh [ __ ] you know man so is
this pretty good I liked it yeah I liked
it a lot to you it's it's funny because
um I think some there was some kind of
like like I said the the director who
also did Death gasm which was also very
funny it was like another horror comedy
it's like about a death metal band I
think that might be on shudder I was
like yeah I saw it like a couple of
months ago so I remember being funny but
um yeah so I guess like before this came
out I guess there was some kind of like
controversy like the director like I
said he's from New Zealand and
apparently he got into like a Twitter
fight with somebody
okay so like
there was this person I do a movie
critic or something like that I can't
remember like all the details but they
use the n-word like a bunch of people
like called them out on using the n-word
and then the director of this movie
defended the person that it and said
that everybody was like driving her to
suicide or her attempted murder or
something like that so it was like this
big like Twitter feud so um you know so
the production company for this movie
who had just bought it there were like
oh geez okay and they're like you know
we don't like whatever he did it seems
crazy [ __ ] whatever we're still putting
the movie out
worried about it so there was just like
that whole thing but yeah I don't really
know a lot about it and I didn't know
about it watching this and I don't
really you know who cares yeah that's
what I mean I don't really care about
that kind of [ __ ] I'm just watching the
movie like if it's a good movie and if
it's like entertaining it so maybe that
was the shenanigans maybe they didn't
want to give us a theatrical release
because of ideological purity I don't
[ __ ] know to me that's a church lady
[ __ ] I don't care what people think I
also don't care what they say they come
at me personally I'm ready alright so
but I don't need to you know I don't I
don't white knight need to put defend
other people if they can't defend
themselves and there you go now that
somebody I know jetty or some of my
friends that's yeah of course but those
are friends people I don't know I don't
read them because I might be defending a
serial killer I don't know stay away
from that person oh I got you that
[ __ ] might be a big [ __ ]
might be a murderer or a child molester
some pedo crack or something I don't
[ __ ] know so I just stay out of other
people's business when it comes to stuff
like that I yeah I largely do as well so
like I said let him fight [ __ ] them they
probably wouldn't like me anyway let
them fight okay well like I said it's
not a real fight it's not real [ __ ] them
all right they can't [ __ ] even go
can't go toe-to-toe then I'm not worried
about it yeah so like I said it's a
great movie though yeah and I didn't
even hear it until after until like you
know I just watched the movie because we
thought the trailer got a four and a
half out of five stars on xbox yeah and
I liked Daniel Radcliffe I've like yeah
pretty much everything else that he's
been in and he's great in this
everybody's great in this like the girl
that plays his girlfriend is great
the villain is great you know and it's
but I think Samara weaving kind of
steals it though is a movie easily
better than birds of prey this could
compete with John went three and I think
had it been had it been promoted right
it would have reflected that at the box
office might have yeah I definitely
would have beat birds of prey at the box
off like I said if you like I mean if
you go into it knowing that it's like a
video game movie and it's very
over-the-top it's very cartoonish it's
very like fast-paced and like come on
out but you know what I mean if you like
that type of movie then you will
probably love funny and it's violent
yeah yeah yeah and colorful looks great
yeah so you know if you're into that
kind of thing then check it out
[Music]